well I can't believe I'm saying what I
think Consciousness is but
I'm horribly unqualified but but I but
who's qualified yeah right anyone with
it so let's go uh so uh so so either
feeling that yeah and and plenty of
people have said this before that that
uh Consciousness is what a type of
information flow feels like uh you know
more particularly I think it's what a uh
a type of data structure feels like when
it tells itself a story about itself
yeah if you see a circularity there
because we're defining Consciousness in
terms of someone so itself feels like
and then the question is well what does
it feel right right so the hard problem
let's let's uh let's solve it you know I
I have someone by the way who's
premiering in two hours from now named
Terence Deacon look at who he believes
he's solved the heart problem several
people believe they've solved the heart
problem and usually it means that
they've that they have a completely
different ontology oh I'm gonna I'm
looking forward to watching it I'm gonna
you're not Terence Deacon have you heard
of him uh name's familiar but no he's a
linguist well he's a neuroanthropologist
and he studied under Chomsky he says he
disagrees with Chomsky about everything
except politics he's extremely extremely
bright and has an extreme what I call a
Velton it's an all-encompassing world
view such that it's a framework through
which you interpret the world so it's
more than simply a world view it's this
philosophy that you have such that you
can pose virtually any question to
someone someone who has a belt on
showing and someone like say Sam Harris
or Jordan Peterson you can ask Jordan
Peterson a question about anything like
why do birds fly like that he would say
it's because the edible mother he has a
framework I mean that can be a useful
thing but don't you think in a way it is
being stuck in part of the landscape uh
maybe a very useful part of the
landscape but
um so right you mentioned it's extremely
useful yes so when you don't have one at
least like for myself it's a
destabilizing place to be you're in
constant you're tentative your
rudderless but you're also not kidding
yourself
well I don't I don't know
I I don't know because then that depends
on so does our model of reality create
reality so it doesn't mean that if you
have a model it just is so there's
something called phenomenology so my
thought is that
um
I think it's clear that at some level
information that is undergoing a certain
Dynamics
itself it feels like something
um and
you know I think it it is
maybe enough for that that data
structure to
inspect itself
keep a story of itself
uh you know as it as it computes its way
to its next state and its next state and
at next in its next state it it has it
has this self-monitoring capability uh
and and ends up
telling itself that it's conscious okay
because it it inspects its own
inspection of itself uh at infant item
um and so so
if
um
you know if information can be conscious
in some way and
the universe is in at least some sense
informational it it can be you know it
can be thought to encode information any
particle encodes some type of
information even if it don't only about
its own existence then uh you can
imagine this spectrum of Consciousness
uh
and so
the so bernardo's sort of
pan psychism uh version of pan psychism
is
one in which he says that he says that
um
that the Consciousness is the most
fundamental element not the material
um I think you can be a pan psychist and
and not say that I think
we you know back to our discussion of
dualities these you could have two
completely different stories about the
world
um and completely different mathematical
Frameworks for describing its Dynamics
but they are ultimately describing the
same thing
and I think that's the case with
Consciousness I think
um
I think you can
take for example a conscious human mind
uh which we we can't argue has it has
Consciousness and you start taking
things away you scale down its ability
to tell stories about itself to
self-inspect okay you can for example
go on a Meditation Retreat and learn to
be be purely in the moment and and
only aware and and you can learn to
suppress all of the chatter all of the
internal dialogue you can suppress all
cognition uh you know essential periods
to a point where you are only perceiving
okay so you you still have a qualia but
you're not telling yourself a story
about that about that you're just
you're essentially just
being the data structure that your brain
has assembled about the outside world
without
without analyzing it okay so you know
that this is clear it's clear that our
subjective worlds are informational okay
that all this detail needs coded and so
so
is there anything special about that
information structure that's just the
output of your you know visual cortex
etc etc that that you know presents you
this this image of the visual world is
that data structure conscious uh or or
that data structure plus your you know
your attention module which is
so so you can you can really pair things
down so that you only have the the
minimum amounts that that you know you
can you can possibly have and still be a
person
um and it seems that that is still
conscious
okay so what's what's the difference
then
to the data structure that represents
your
the the
uh the subjective world that your brain
assembled and
a data structure that contains similar
information that's not in a person well
the difference is that
it's not constantly telling itself a
story about what it says and it has no
memory so if you if you I mean imagine
for example that the entire universe was
conscious and was aware of itself or you
know it told oh that was a star that
exploded I just made a Galaxy
but then you take away that story and it
just is the data structure of all this
stuff
uh what will be the difference between
just being Mata
unconscious matter and you know this
completely memoryless uh you know
conscious thing and my argument is that
there's no difference
and the thing that has no memory or
capacity to self-inspect
isn't really conscious but that at least
gives you a way to have a a spectrum of
Consciousness like as soon as something
starts to have both a model of the world
and can tell itself a story about its
moral of the world then it can start
telling itself it's conscious and and by
the way it's not that's not an illusion
the the whole idea that Consciousness is
an illusion I think is is as as bad a
fallacy as saying that the
you know the holographic principle bulk
is an illusion and the boundary is not
in that case where the universe is
conscious and it's not conscious of
anything you're saying that it's as if
there's two states of Consciousness one
that's about something and then one that
is just conscious pure Consciousness and
that's something that you can access
when you're in meditation well I feel
like
you know Consciousness I think we
thank you
I think it's a poorly defined concept
it's you know it it really emerges when
we get to start telling ourselves that
we have it
and and
you know we could we we can observe our
our own Consciousness because we are we
literally are part of the data structure
that this Consciousness is okay it's not
like we're
a separate you know homunculus observing
the the data structure that our brain
synthesize we are that data structure
okay we we that that literally is what
we are and inside that data structure
there's a model of ourselves
okay which we can also inspect
um
and so I think
uh
Consciousness is just a it is in this
sense an emergent phenomenon
but there's no
no very hard line I I think for when it
emerges you know I'm I started all the
saying I'm no expert and and then
gave us super uh long treaties as though
um I know anything but uh
this is the picture that fills the least
contradictory to me you just watched a
clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy